this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
hello everyone it's great to be here can
you hear me okay in the back yes I want
to know how many people are from Hawaii
here in this room how many people have
been to Hawaii how many would like to go
to Hawaii okay this room has good
judgment I know that um it's great to be
here I have very fond memories of my
days to Stanford but the the biggest
memory my head was when I was doing my
surgical residency at Stanford Medical
Center I was a resident chief resident
Stanford I was so poor that I bought a
Cadillac for about six hundred dollars
mmm it was a great car except for the
fact that it didn't have a reverse gear
so I could only drive forward but not
backwards so it took a lot of extra time
to look for parking stalls where I could
you know drive forward at the at the end
of my shift and the Envy in the
headlights didn't work so I'm driving on
the freeway I have to turn on the
emergency blinker so I could see the
road every other second basically so but
I've really found memories is great to
be back here and I'm looking forward to
telling a little bit about what we do at
Sky ventures um this is my office please
come and visit anytime sky is a word
that we invent it's we create it kai is
the Hawaiian word for water ocean of
course sky is the blue sky so where the
ocean joins the sky is the horizon right
which holds infinite breath and
possibilities hence the name sky
ventures and our business model is very
simple all right we look for the
smartest people the most ingenious ideas
we can find a global scale and we
transform them into businesses they're
profitable high-growth that can do
something good for the world that we
live in and as you can see if our model
and then to disrupt and inspire and the
word disrupt is in there because we like
to focus on the kind of business that
really game changers because it takes
just as much time and energy and work to
build something that's really a game
changer in something that's incremental
hence would like to focus on disruptive
what is interesting however is we do all
of this in a part of the world that is
the most isolated land
on earth this is a google earth shot of
Hawaii so for those who've been there
before did anybody go to Hawaii not on
an airplane so we are in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean so we are about 2,400
miles from California and almost 4,000
miles from Japan highly isolated but the
point of today's sort of sharing with
you we do is the fact that
entrepreneurship can take place anywhere
by anyone in any subject matter all
right it matters not where you located
Silicon Valley Stanford is a great
fantastic location it is the mecca in
the minds of many but it's not a
requisite it is not a requisite for
innovation and it's not a requisite for
creating great enterprises so I will
like to invite all of you we have a
chance to come and visit us in Hawaii
and come and visit us at described
ventures would love to sort get to know
you and share with you what we do so
just a plug for Hawaii well while we're
here all right it has the highest
percentage of millionaires in United
States at you will fight every celebrity
entrepreneur in Hawaii shopping at the
same whole foods and Safeway all right
Oprah lives here now lives there Schwab
lives there Pierre Omidyar is there
Steve Case is there everyone is there we
have the longest life expectancy United
States and we have in fact Honolulu's
for the one of the 10th healthiest
cities in the entire world very ethnic
diverse for those who prefer Hawaii you
know that and we also have our own time
zone Hawaiian standard time so when I
was growing up Hawaiian Standard Time
used to mean that used to mean that it
means to me 30 minutes late basically um
but this is also very interesting the
attractive lifestyle also makes us one
of the largest importers of
entrepreneurs in the entire world I
would say also a Silicon Valley we
probably have the highest concentration
of entrepreneurs who are between
successes yeah we're between failures of
anywhere else in the world and it's the
perfect
place to incubate to start and to
nurture the next really big idea besides
where the most isolated landmass nowhere
else no one really is going to steal
your idea until it's been nurture along
far enough and we take a lot of young
people every summer so last summer we
have 15 interns and we had kids from
everywhere including Stanford Harvard
Yale Princeton Columbia all around the
United States and the world in fact and
got a call in March of last year from a
fellow who I did a summer internship
with us year before he said hey dr. Wu
he sat down I'm gonna quit Columbia and
start my own company and I said Chris
that's great have you told your dad and
so he finished Columbia and he's now
working a company you know with us so
like many other companies here in
Silicon Valley our basic guidelines are
not so different right go after big
business at least a billion dollars
market size strong IP good management
team and everything we do we hope at the
end of the day would benefit the world
and the community that we live in we
also pay a lot of tension to Asia and
through China in all that we do as a
very important market that we go after
who is from China here okay thank you so
we have a number of a portfolio
companies six of which are really sort
of a very much in the midst of being
grown and looking at exit so I will
share with you briefly some of these
companies and by the way so Hawaiian
style hawaiian time all right very
casual if you have a question raise your
hand I'll be happy to entertain them at
at any time so we really have to tour
two categories of business this one is
the area of novel materials right these
are materials that i think are great
platforms that can grow in many
different ways from multiple market
applications and so the top three to tag
sepia polymers and I genex true tag is
an edible bar code then this
extraordinarily information-rich very
inexpensive that can be eaten and can
tag everything that goes into your body
basically so think about the
implications of that
CBI polymers is a green tech for
environmental radiation which I'll tell
you a little bit more about and it has a
very large role in Fukushima in the last
couple years then I genex is working on
the most advanced technology for an
artificial cornea to treat blindness to
restore vision for the 10 million people
in the world we're blind today so think
about these technologies right these
could very well be prototypic companies
right here in Silicon Valley except
we're doing this in Hawaii we also have
health care services platforms including
these three companies our sky vision
institute is is focused on vision
surgery everything you can imagine
refractive cataract oculoplastic
glaucoma retina surgery as well as
corneal transplantation we haven't asked
the Institute that has capacity to do
about 15,000 surgeries a year for the
early detection of cancer and and we're
looking also looking to build the
largest of corneal transplantation
center in China today and finally we're
putting a the next vision of sky
together which will be a fun that's
going to be dedicated to software and
and a healthcare IT which I'll tell you
a little bit about oh so true Tex true
tanks is an edible barcode and as you as
you find a common denominator for all
these companies or three fold one a
really big problem that needs to be
solved to a very unique solution or
three a great team so why are we in this
business well counterfeit is a big
business in fact it is considerably the
largest business in the world right
margins are huge Oh everybody's in it it
touches every product every region
everywhere and so in essence what we
have created is another form of
identification like a fingerprint like a
retina scan except in this case we can
do it in a very large volume and create
massive amount of information on a
customized basis so
a picture's worth a thousand were so a
quick kind of a news clip on this
particular hop next I'm cracking down on
counterfeit drugs how an edible security
tool is being used to take on the
illegal industry someone through that
value we see barcodes these days on just
about everything we buy there's a local
company that makes those codes edible
not so much as a tasty treat but to make
food and drugs safer Manolo Morales
reports the pharmaceutical market has an
estimated value of 800 billion dollars
worldwide about ten percent of the
market is considered counterfeit so this
is an eighty billion dollar counterfeit
market we confident corporated so to
speak much bigger than any corporation
we know that's legitimate preventive
measures are taken with more secure
packaging but Hawaii company called true
tag technologies wants to add an extra
dose of security by putting what's
essentially edible barcodes on every
pill and we sprinkle a few of these
think of like a sugar doughnut on a
tablet so that an inspector can take a
to tag reader and read those little
grains of sugar so to speak the truth
tags and tell it has a unique optical
signature each coded tag is smaller than
a grain of sugar it's made of silica
found in many food items and FDA
approved each one carries a unique
spectrum of colors that is detected by a
reader which looks like a microscope to
tag developed the reader which will also
be provided to the pharmaceutical
companies and eventually to the
pharmacists as long as they have a line
of sight they can read our tags and
validate with their security teams or QA
teams who are around the world making
sure the supply chain is safe trutech
technologies recently won the grand
prize at the prison so I think that
gives you a sort of an idea we started
with a silicon wafer much like what we
do here in Silicon Valley for
semiconductor manufacturing and we can
we can convert them into basically
silicone in the process we can embed
billions of combinations spectral codes
to the material but the beauty is this
right silica is already approved as an
excipient in drugs it's been used in
many many types of pharmaceuticals hence
there is no regulatory risk associated
with the development of this particular
product and so again as you saw earlier
give you a sense of scale alright grain
of salt green a sugar and green the tree
tags so in this particular case we can
insert over billion combination of
spectral code and we can read it the
simple reflection from a light source
can be picked up in deciphered as the
basis for tracking tagging anti
counterfeiting and identification so a
light shine on a tablet can be read by
an ipad enabled reader in this case we
can tell you this is lipitor 20
milligrams a lock code expiration day
manufacturer site and so on and so forth
and this is a very powerful technology
sighs the market is quite large there's
one and a half trillion tablets made
every year in the world today of which
one third are branded or high-value
products so that's the target for the
counterfeiters and and so that basically
makes up the 80 billion dollar
counterfeit drug market but unlike a
product shoes or Gucci bag right when
you take a counterfeit medicine it could
have catastrophic consequences to the
end user so this is not just about
economics but it's also about something
that's extremely important right for
society at large oh we can down we can
do these things for roughly one cent
appeal or less so so that's roughly a
five billion dollar sort of your
opportunity for us just in the
pharmaceutical side equation so for
every two percent of market away able to
penetrate is worth about 100 million
dollars in revenue basically so it's a
powerful it's a powerful technology it's
an interesting sector but we're not
limited of course to pharmaceuticals you
think about all the different things
that we ingest or things that we don't
ingest whether it's nira chinese milk
powder where there is computer chips you
know why the folks from our Chateau
Lafite had come and talk to us and say
hey this is a really interesting
be possible put this in a very high-end
you know branded our wine and spirits we
said sure of course is possible however
could you send us six cases of Chateau
Lafite so we can do proper rd on the
equator so every one of our portfolio
companies has an executive team that
seasons and understand the domain
extremely well soak a man's fear was a
president he was a CEO of a company that
he helped started call of 10 tix started
with five employees just a startup
company grew to a point where eventually
was sold to the Carlyle Group Peter Wong
is our chief alpen officers spent many
years in Silicon Valley a very
transaction oriented attorney I was
involving IPO of ugly frog and caucus
sports and so great management in the
understanding security business
understands transactions so that's true
text any quick questions if I move on I
genex I genex is not one of our material
science companies in this particular
case were focusing on developing a
solution to solve the problem of corneal
blindness mmm this company came to be
when I was on an airplane flying back to
Hawaii from California andis annex to an
ophthalmologist who kind of shared with
me sir the problem of the world not
having enough donors for cornea organs
that large and so it turns out it's a
it's a huge problem particularly in Asia
because a number of cultural and
religious reasons Asians by large are
very reluctant to donate organs so on
the Left what you see is a picture of a
blind corner on the right the same
cornea after transplant so it turns out
that more corners are transplanted world
today than heart lung liver kidney
pancreas combined there is the number
one human transplant procedure in the
world 10 million people in the world
today could benefit from a corneal
transplantation the entire worlds donor
base is only about 100,000 which means
ninety-nine percent of the people who
are blind in the world today will
basically never have a chance to see for
as long as they
and that's the reason we embark upon
this project so they're even with the
one percent of population that can take
could conceivably access a human donor
cornea there are many drawbacks the
rejection rate is roughly twenty percent
so one of every five cornea transplant
rejects because there's no matching that
takes place there's no blood typing
or matching there's of course the risk
of disease transmission with a human
donated organ and they have to be a
lifelong topical immunosuppressive
medication so there are clearly our
limitations so we have developed
material from recombinant human collagen
that has this very unique property to
allow epithelial ization and nerve
growth to take place within the Oregon
we have now seen a very long-term
follow-up in a group of patients that
have been transplanted and we have just
finished the completion of a
manufacturing facility that can supply
bases the entire North American market
right in Honolulu and this material
interesting enough can be laser sculpted
to give the right refractive power which
makes it extraordinarily interesting a
powerful because conceivably this
technology can be used not only to treat
the 10 million people a corneal
blindness but to be used for refractive
correction things such as presbyopia as
well which impacts basically everyone
over the age of 55 so our Vantage's are
multifold unlimited supply we're no
longer be restricted by the one percent
so a lottery for someone who wants to
regain their vision off-the-shelf
convenience if your surgeon you want to
schedule cage for three o'clock Tuesday
next week you can go ahead and schedule
that surgery you don't have to wait for
someone to pass away will and donate
their cornea or someone should be able
to pick that up process at harvested and
transported to a recipient and the fact
that allows nerve and epithelial growth
is extremely important from a clinical
standpoint and no life long leaf on
University suppressive um we have an
opportunity to capture only a two
billion dollar market opportunity but
equally important we have a chance to do
something that fundamentally is
extremely important for humanitarian
standpoint the 10 million people around
the world who are blind and who
basically would never
really have a chance in without the
technology such as this Doug post who
was the c 00 a physics which was
acquired by ammo for 1.3 billion and
then we're so to abbott's 1.2 is our
vice chairman and Tony Lee from Silicon
Valley who's done three venture-backed
medical device companies all
successfully exit it is our chief
operating officer so again the same
thing right big market strong IP great
management tool except is done all in
Hawaii we also have another health care
services companies I'll go through these
very quickly we run a surgery center
that has a capacity to 15,000 surges
here with 13 surgeons this is really
sort of a very synergistic play with our
you know court I business when you come
to Hawaii please come over if you need
to have eye surgery it will be on the
house just just give me a call this is
this is the lobby / center and it's
beautifully constructed and this is part
of a franchise that we hope to sort of
expand throughout Asia in China as well
I of course as I mentioned before we do
all types of eye surgery and we also
have an endoscopy center where we do
colonoscopy and ask these for early
detection of cancer and similarly if you
ever want to have a colonoscopy please
give us a call CBI polymer this is the
last company i'll share with you before
we go to a Q&A so in the course of
developing dumb or artificial cornea we
had to assemble a team that's really a
world-class material science and then we
saw an rfp on the US government asking
someone to develop material that could
bind radioactive particles so we have
this group a really really great
scientist sitting around the room and
say hey could we could we try this of
course you know that's that wasn't them
a area of our commercial expertise but
we certainly knew about materials and we
knew about binding and at a very deep
level so we competed for that a price we
want we got a bunch of funding from the
US government and then eventually
develop a product
in Reno that's the for surface
decontamination of radioactive and
hazardous chemical materials and so it
turns out there this is an industry
that's not the most advanced with
respect to innovation the disposal of
hazardous waste has never been really a
sexy area of pursue for technologists
and the cost of waste disposal as you
can imagine right is really tied to both
volume of and the weight of ways that
you generate basically so the economics
are huge in this in this area so we have
development material that scatters
exquisite ability to bind surface
contaminants and again pictures are
worth a thousand words so this is a
regular asphalt surface somebody's
driving you can see the oil and the
grease and grime on that surface you
apply this blue gel you wait for it to
dry and when you remove it I think you
can appreciate that on this slide you
can see the air in the back already been
power wash three times everything has
been picked up and contained in that
particular gel this is a mold and mildew
on a concrete sidewalk you can send it
before the during and the after this is
a bilge tank petroleum now before and
after and so imagine the amount of labor
and cost savings involved in the
deployment of this particular technology
so let's see if you're going to clean a
hundred thousand square feet of real
illogically waste using traditional
technology which is really a soap and
water radiat wash detergents you
probably generate around 140,000 pounds
of waste in a cost of disposing that
based on weight and volume will cost you
about 350 million dollars using this
technology because the material at the
end of the day is very compressible it's
very lightweight you don't require the
use of water we can do the same jophur
and generally only about 13,000 pounds
of weights so the cost of disposal for
that is roughly only 33 million so
you're saving in this particular case
very 317 million dollars by the
deployment of this particular technology
so we have customers all
around the world in all sectors of
Industry at this point and then of
course as mo all of you know right
Fukushima happened about two years ago
March 11th and so and this is going to
be a very long very costly no cleanup in
many ways right Japan is like a brother
to us by virtue of fact that we're in
Hawaii so we did a lot of work to
volunteer our time and efforts to help
with remediation and the cleanup in
Japan and so so here was a clip that was
I want to show you from from CNN from
mom no what if i told you that you could
peel away toxic waste and radiation just
peel it away with just a little bit of
spray yes it could be true and happening
right now it's our big eye and its next
welcome back devastating just doesn't
seem like a strong enough word for what
the people of Joplin Missouri are
dealing with right now the city manager
says the tornado split the town in half
a storm chaser in the area says parts of
the city are just unrecognizable now
take a moment and imagine the massive
cleanup for this area and all that
debris that you're looking at beyond
carting everything off in trucks there
is always a danger of chemical exposure
in a cleanup effort of this magnitude
and think about Japan and their cleanup
efforts from the tsunami they not only
have to worry about cleaning up debris
but also radiation one of the products
being used to clean up radiation into in
Japan is actually called decon gel the
manufacturers are based in Hawaii and
decon gel has the consistency of hair
gel if you will I'm here to tell us much
more about this as I believe Zimmerman
she spoke to the inventor of this
miracle goo Eileen thanks for coming on
the show first of all tell us a little
bit about how this works decenzo the gel
that goes on is to tell / radioactive
waste hazardous waste cleanup meth lab
anything that's any microscopic
particles and it hardens and then it can
just be rolled up and thrown away so it
encapsulates what evers has it is so
that it doesn't week or leach out that's
really space and it lowers the hazardous
level of the waist and then it's just
pop out and so you just you just spray
it on or brush it on it's brushed on and
it can be brushed on almost any material
whether it's concrete or like a lab
bench would it just goes on when your
gel its spread really thin its rise and
then it can be rolled up fold it and
compressed and thrown out and what sort
of hazardous waste are we talking about
that this gel can actually clean up well
in Japan is helping to clean up
radioactive waste but it can also be
used for any kinds of hazardous waste
playsound the department of energy has
used it in their labs clean up for
williams and it can also can use
anything that's toxic it was used to
help clean up there was a problem in our
Western Hungary with some abilities that
had an alkali sludge problem and they
had to clean up alkali with it which can
your skin on contact so that went down
and it cleaned it up anything like that
anything that's dangerous sure it will
be around and from what I understand
this is actually discovered by accident
how did that happen oh well he'll the
company is high school who then
we discovered by accident but just like
the name yahoo really wasn't you know it
doesn't really not the true acronym but
again you get the idea this is one of
our team members making a donation to
the japan hyper rescue team helping to
clean up this sir chief scientist in
fukushima and so this is an automobile
that was driven in and out of fukushima
if you're in japan if you see a car with
a Fukushima license plate on it don't go
near right because likely there's still
residual radiation on it and the
radiation has been track in this
particular case where you apply the gel
you strip it off you take away all the
radiation and you can do the same thing
of tires and so on and so forth so
people are spraying entire automobiles
and buildings and so on and so forth so
this is a kindergarten outside of
Fukushima with the kids since the event
of marched 11 for six months they
couldn't go outside to play at all
because everything surrounding the
building was radioactive so we actually
assist the Japan government and we did a
completely contamination of the entire
school so the kids go outside and play
and that was part of the basis for sort
of CNN coverage of the particular event
and technology thanks to one of the best
publicist in the world Paula page and so
as a commercial opportunity 31 countries
have nuclear power plants in this in
this world and their three 439 nuclear
reactors every 18 months every one of
these reactors needs to be maintained
and shut down and restarted and clean
basically so very interesting story no
long term opportunity um based on the
technology we've also launched not a
secondary brand called press store for
environmental building restoration this
is a law enforcement officers monument
Washington DC you can see the before the
doing and the after because their idea
is we can actually remove a debris and
dirt from really fine surfaces you know
without any damage or injury to that
surface this is st. Vincent's in New
York a very beautiful on european-style
church and they have many years of soot
carbon deposit on the wall
but certainly they don't want to sort
you know power washed inside of of the
church you can see the before and the
after on the run for tile on the
limestone and in fact this is an entire
wall in front of the word the candles
are being burned you can see through the
difference they're basically see their
polymers so our next thing is we're
going to actually put another fun
together that's going to focus more on
the software and the in the healthcare
IT side of the equation as well you know
we realize there are lots of these
accelerators there are you know
springing up everywhere in the country
there are many of them in many parts of
world and there are several there you
know very well known here TechStars y
combinator and so on and so forth so how
many of you have entry one of those
competitions how many of you plan to if
you enter one of these competitions if
you win come and see us or Hawaii we
would love to work with you vacuum
support you and help you because that's
the business that we're in is working
with really smart people with great
ideas on developing technologies that
have a really fundamental impact in the
world and guess what you can do it in a
part of the world right there's very
little traffic it's got great weather
you can body serve boogie board right
you can go off Hawaii on time and you
can live longer than anybody else um to
help me with this venture involves
couple guys Dennis Coleman who is
introduced to me by tom then I was the
founder of semantic fourth largest
software company world inventor spell
check and Bill Malone who just retired
from Cisco as their CTO he's from Hawaii
you grew up there you just moved back
there so we're gonna you know forge a
fun to really look at your young
entrepreneurs in this in this area so
that's it that's the lineup s sky
ventures and so if you have a chance i
would really urge you to come to Hawaii
come and visit us will be very happy to
talk about any ideas and innovations you
might have that we really have a
fundamental disruptive impact on the
world that we live them and now so I
hope to see one or several of you in our
photo lineup for for next year
thank you very much and I'm open for
questions now please just raise your
hand have a question and now two
questions one on the cornea transplant
does insurance on the numbers of the
potential market does insurance play a
role on that in that at all in those
numbers like for example like um let's
say there's 10 million people that need
the cornea transplant and good like do
you say X amount of those people would
need insurance to cover the procedure
and final in church cover that procedure
very good question so market numbers the
two billion it's only the addressable
market in the parts of the world where
people have the ability to afford to pay
for cornea with the true self pay with
your insurance but as a corporate policy
we have also established in non for
profit charity with a specific purpose
of donating cornea in those regions the
world where people would not have the
ability to pay either through themselves
or three insurance how do you make sure
your honor prayers don't just go surfing
all the time um we can't but there but
they're self driven right it's now if
they go surfing all the time and that's
all they did ultimately they're not
going to be successful alright so now if
they're not going to be successful
they're not going to last very long so
there's a process of self elimination
and and it's interesting so you know I'm
a swimmer so I swim almost daily in the
ocean before the Sharks come and uh and
it is great it's sort of like my um my
sort of my problem solving time you know
in that water for 40 minutes so it's
Hawaii offers a really interesting
environment but I think people their
work just as hard they're just as driven
just as committed except you have a
lifestyle that's really really you know
I'm matched basically because I'm always
going to slack off they can do it in
Palo Alto as well as Hawaii basically so
okay personal
teristics do you find make the best
ladies with this successful much been
asked and so very um that's a very good
question oh one is an enormous amount of
optimism in general the second is a very
high level of tolerance for pain because
right startups are difficult all right
you're mad with challenges I like
walking into an established company
where things are kind of laid out here
you have to sort you know figure out the
map and find the car and find the gas
and drive the car yourself I mean it's
all about creating something for nothing
so you have to really love it you know
to you know it's right at it I'm more
specific questions are true tag and
scalability of the problem I just
wondering about your capex and that we
never talk about scalability is already
in a state where you have a min
important order quantity that will
actually apply to the probability of the
actual tag itself what do you do by the
way I my to business development for I'm
in exposure okay all right just curious
it's a very good question and so we have
the capacity so you're right it's a
catch-22 basically so we have a large
portfolio of prospective clients you
know globally basically but we've also
sort of figure enough of them then the
nitty-gritties of this technology we
understand the efficient scale so when
it comes to pharmaceuticals yeah no
question we can we can do massive
volumes at when send a pill and make it
a very predictable business from a capex
and nonprofit standpoint sure it depends
you're raised in the supply chain for
the silicon you know is there a
percentage feel you rate when you're
going up your main passion I don't know
the answer to that huh Oh Phoebe mind
describing the moment where you kind of
walked out of med school and made the
decision to go aboard the innovation
medical practice both their cause yes
what money isn't Michael I caught on
fire Oh and so I actually then to walk
from medical school to business I came
to Stanford oh you my training as a
surgeon and so I got into Stanford I was
resident I was chief resident but um but
being a surgeon I'm being a stanford it
was it was just a great place because
everyone was entrepreneurial and sort of
the concept being creative and
problem-solving was seen all around you
so I was very much you know bitten by
the bug so the idea was really to look
for problems to solve in the operating
room because there are many and
eventually got into the business of
creating inventing you know devices and
solutions that could solve these
problems and we discover sure enough
there are people who would invest and
paid large sums of reward for come in
with a great solution and that's how the
transformation eventually took place and
when the cattle I caught on fire really
crystallized everything else so the
question yeah um when you say like high
tolerance of pain like even eat them for
their specific context um you play
sports yeah what did you play soccer
soccer and what was training legend you
can't stop the days when you're pushed
so hard that you just think oh my gosh I
cannot go another five minutes
say it's like mono that so again them
like more born a mental game a mental
game oh absolutely well absolutely is
very much a mental game sure it sits in
cars a certain amount of mental
toughness I think right I mean it's not
for everyone not everyone is different
right it's about casting life right if
you're really tall and thin you
shouldn't be a wrestler it should be a
volleyball basketball player
entrepreneurship is the same thing some
people thrive in conditions where
there's uncertainty and there's
challenges and imperfection other people
really hate that oh so it really selects
for you know different people no right
or wrong no good or bad just everybody's
different basically and I'm so so I'm
just thinking about you the application
of the promise that you won't get into
as many spread out about mountains with
City issues and other issues only by
actually we try things out you actually
know its activity book somewhere and yet
I don't really know what things all my
wells perfect but even when you have a
great caught up when it's actually maybe
having 12 issues in medical how do you
spell that how do you know that this is
something like it's a rare moment when
things all go well as an entrepreneur
but it's no more dangerous than walking
across the street on a friday night in
palo alto you know either basically so I
mean it's just a constant sort of
assessment of your risk in your return
of course you want to do thoughtful you
want to be strategic you want to
understand your wrist so you can deal
with it no proactively basically but you
know entrepreneurship is a risky it's a
risky game basically and now and that's
that's just the nature of the beast I
think
sir this is a product question dr. Wu on
the polymerase product mom when you
clean the radiation off the car the
vehicle is there a method that you can
tell the percentage that it's fully
clean sure sure I could counter right so
with a Geiger counter you got to be able
to know how much radiation there's
before how much arms after how much you
capture it's actually fairly a fairly
standard easy it's easy to do basically
yeah whoa ok I see five hands go at the
same time but will you do with the waist
yesterday it depends very much on what
it is that you're removing all right so
if it's radioactive material they're
very strict statue that you have to
follow all right so what we're doing is
really you're capturing and transporting
that to a safe place basically but if
it's you know dirt off your backyard
right the material was sent herbal super
compressible water-soluble biodegradable
so you can actually you know you catch a
literally throw in the trash basically
follows with another in front of
question on the treetops and consent of
nursing of some crazy amount of
combination that you can make and it
works based on reflection so I was
wondering if that
nice to do with some sort of different
pattern you do know the surface of that
whether you are Ashley Idol pores surat
recruit nanopore structures within a
silica basically can you talk a bit
about skype ventures business model and
its relationship to the entrepreneurs
I'm getting the sense that something in
this wizard like an incubator or puree
you see person understanding so it's not
a pure of you see in the sense that we
don't just deploy capital but we're
quite hands-on so typical typically we
will work with an entrepreneur in a very
early stage but we're actually really
sorry you know roll up our sleeves
because we're operators you know we
understand sort of the pains well you
know what it is to do a startup company
so will vow ND ploy capital but human
resources and time and energy so it is a
hybrid it is very much a hybrid between
traditional venture capital and a
technology accelerator yeah good
question how did you you mention with
the cornea product you've got the arm
that does that for those who can't
afford it you know kind of it and so
kind of a corporate social
responsibility how do you how do you
determine how much to put into that
versus you know being a venture capital
firm happy where do you draw those how
do you draw those lot of yours that you
making that call is that you know any
any thoughts on that balance between the
social responsibility in that sense and
the you know the profit making aspects
sure that's a it's a really good
question it's me that's probably a
fairly long discussion that sound you
know we could share after the session
also but but sky ventures really you
know as the parent company we we we
allowed our portfolio companies who make
their own decisions you know about
business models but it has to write make
sense because the business has to be
successful all right you can in order
for the philanthropy to be successful
all right so the car and the horse has
to be no short of right order basically
but there's a happy medium somewhere
where you can truly do something good
for the world we can also build an
enterprise that staying that that's kind
of that's kind of a great brand that's
profitable and see a lot of growth ahead
of it so like anything else right its
judgments right
judgments how did you expand the part I
about to do health care system yeah so
yeah how they work like it's been like
marketing are you for internal yes yeah
we're Spartans on anything oh really
Shambo okay I was just there Oh doodle
hey good health care system is very good
it's very different but is changing
involved I wasn't sure until just last
year I went to Qingdao and they have the
largest corneal transplantation
hospitals in all of China and but their
volume is not very large because there's
a lot of donors basically Wow so I think
China is the it's a powerful economy
it's developing very quickly and things
are evolving and I think but it's a very
different system so our basic approach
in China is to work with very strong
Chinese partners all right that can
understand best ways to sort internet
markets and work that market what we
provide is a very fundamental technology
all right your sources supply that's
that is extremely rare and valuable well
but we can we cannot go and learn the
system in every country from scratch
right so for China for Japan for Korea
for your for that matter right without
working with local partners basically so
that's that's our fundamental approach
question about of what kind of
technology based product at your Ashley
try to see like how long do you prefer
blame like something that's what really
change the entire entire field who is
going to take maybe 15 years to try now
are you actually really ought to get a
bill or are you more interested in
something getting involved with
something that is going to equities
all's good night what kinds of the surf
is up for not well something's going to
take 15 years is best at a university
where that's the function of the
university of academic research
institution right is basic fundamental
knowledge basically right we we were we
would love to be in the position where
any of you have an idea right that we
can prove if there is validity or
concept in a commercial marketplace
because your test you can do right we're
not in the business of creating
fundamental technology from scratch
because that's unpredictable it could
take your year it could take you a
hundred years and and we don't have a
hundred years right so really it's about
testing and validating commercially
viable ideas but not fundamental
research right fundamental research is
for the university basically back can
you get a couple examples of how sky has
helped the company's you cover up there
beyond here funding I sorry i couldnt
hitter second part of the question how
sky is helped a couple of the example
companies beyond the pure finances sure
sure in a number of these instances
we're sort of founder if you will you
know of the business right so in the
case of to text for example right it was
a very smart scientist who have a great
innovation right but there was no
management team there was no initial
proof of concept there's no development
of the reader technology there was no
manufacturing right so so we asked I
actually played a role as part of that
he has part of founding team a favor
right we set up you know these different
components that we can you prove a
concept demonstrate there's commercial
value and then ramp from there right so
yeah the fact told me we are a founder
in many of these businesses if you will
much more than just the financial
investor how do you really find the
technology for these businesses so you
say that you're in the business are
really accelerating commercially viable
technology we're looking at strategies
you use to find where this technologies
being developed so that it's some like
anything else in life right it's
serendipity plays a part in that and
it's also about sort of the other
network so for me we have a lot of
network through my alma mater right
Hopkins Stanford Harvard and the likes
well we do a lot of work with you know
different universities you know we fund
there's some types of research we have
we have 15 interns that comes through
our shop every year and everyone in the
brain like really unique interesting
ideas but we're in the business of
people learn anything else right it's
about connecting with really smart
people who with a dream with a dream and
a vision to do something different and
but but no one person can do that alone
right it takes a lot of efforts it takes
a lot of sort of an appetite for risk to
make that happen so we're in the
business of people really and and so I'm
really glad to be here today because I
suspect one of you and many of you have
such an idea or have such a sort of know
dreaming you're in your mind's basically
and you are exactly the folks we want to
be talking to basically very hands-on
question what do you interns do
on the first day of their internship we
require everybody to learn how to do CPR
and use an automatic defibrillator so
they can save somebody's lives during
the course of their internship we and we
signed with a different tasks that you
can under their level of interest right
because so there's enough sort of
technical projects that they're very
sort of a science and technology
oriented and we can actually go into a
lab and work on something some other
folks are more interested in business
right we would put somebody on a supply
chain analysis you know figure out the
capex you know the risk factors and all
that stuff of course but we require
every intern to make a presentation at
the end of the internship on an idea
that they would like to pursue right
kind of a full-blown business plan right
thing through this what would it take
what is this worthwhile how do you make
it a big business how do you plan and do
it and because we want everyone to have
sore some presentation skills so they
can go out there and pitch the idea when
they're done with this internship so
it's it's fairly um it's a it's a it's
fairly flexible actually pleased with
your very busy man apparently their
adventures were involved in I need to
distribute your time um I always swim in
the ocean daily you saw my office
earlier and now I try to distribute my
time again around people but not events
with projects right so every one of our
companies has a leader you know has a
cheap up an officer or CEO whose job in
life is to live and die by that company
right so they're it right the buck stops
with them basically and my job is to
find those kind of people right we
really have the analogy expertise but
the passion to make that business
successful so again I spend most my time
on people and ideas would you say are
areas health care for their unsolved
problems and we're innovation will be
Paula say it will be virtually all
aspects of health care that requires
innovation but i think the area of
healthcare IT in particular is a very
large area for a whole variety of
reasons that that you're aware of and
that's very much an area that we are
particularly interesting and diving in
not much deeper in fact there's an
entrepreneur here I made earlier who's
got a great idea I won't say the name
but we met just about an hour ago would
you say has been your biggest failure
and han ji reporter there's so many um
instead of give you sort of one I think
maybe I can soar summarize for you right
at the end of the day there there are a
lot of factors that have to work in
concert for one of these ventures to be
ultimately successful and timing is you
know is one of them because you operate
in an environment where there are lots
of other smart people in the world with
equally great ideas the Opera
environment where there's lots of
funding and resources in this world
chasing after you know great ideas right
so um I guess the big challenge is you
know you have to know so you know where
you are relative to uh to everything
else it's um it's um I tell people it's
like it's like sailing right you've got
to have a great ship which is your
technology you gotta have a great crew
and so they're not a sale but you also
got to have win basically and you can't
do it without what if one of the three
variables are missing basically well so
we've made all kinds of mistakes of
course right picking the wrong guy for
the management right um you know there
are people who have perfect resume but
when they show up right when they have
to make their own Xerox machine or get
their own coffee in the morning you're
shell-shocked it's oh my gosh I've never
done this before what am I going to do
you don't know that too they really show
up all right you have technology that
looks fantastic and a week later right
someone equally smart comes up with
something that completely obviates you
know that particular technology so these
are all things that happen and but as
they say here right in the valley right
you want to feel early so you can go on
right and
thing wrong with failure the worst thing
has never taken a chance in the first
place what are the ethics you look for
in the people you surround yourself with
Thursday I want them to be smarter and
better looking than I am because then I
don't have anything to worry about right
then they can take care of as many task
as many difficulties as possible all
right always know always you know higher
up recruit up basically and service
providers like Amazon Web Services in
rackspace have made fixed cost starting
an IT companies in 20 at the beginning
what's gonna be the next big thing in
the medical space that similarly lowers
the barriers entry oh there are many I
can talk to you afterwards actually but
but that's but that's extremely valuable
right so now it's a it's an even playing
ground right so so what you need us
people really smart ideas right that
means someone was a great inventor with
a great concept and a critical insight
can be as competitive as some as the
next guy who's got a big infrastructure
behind them because you don't have to
build a stir from scratch basically so
that so the playing field is is really
even that's why being creative and smart
having great insights going to make a
huge difference that's why healthcare IT
is going to be a hot area I think thank
you so is it was actually that airplane
rides um I was flying back and some are
how to do okay we're gonna this is our
first project first compete over the
start of a pennant at all
like the old fashioned way home sat down
took on my checkbook and start the
company basically
luck
you